you play these really damaged peoples
where what is it what is it about these
characters female growing up in this
business I was like the girlfriend and
yeah that's not that complicated fun to
play honestly guys get to play the bad
guy get to play the hero guys get to
play the complicated people for a long
time I don't think women really got a
lot of chance to do that and it it's fun
to dig in deeper and it also says
something that your career has spanned
so long and you've been able to achieve
these kinds of things for such a long
time yeah I'm very very lucky and I'm
totally shocked by this such incredible
performances of all my fellow nominees
in and I won last year so I I wrongly
thought it was a no you went back to
back that's history right it's the first
time since its first time in a long time
I don't know I'm grateful thank you this
was a great run have the kids called you
have you called anybody have you talked
to anybody gets cold any be actually
somebody else asked me that and then I
said to my husband my boyfriend you have
to text the kids and yeah I mean I just
like to be their mom not really there
actor mom yeah no I get that we kind of
minimize that around my parts weird
innit where does this go then in my
office I have a collection I'm becoming
a hoarder so you keep in the office yeah
yes Wow okay that's it's unbelievable
and what does this say about your
choices going forward will you make
continue to make these kinds of choices
because these are great complex
characters I mean I took pretty much
this whole year off mm-hmm just to kind
of rest and recharge and we'll see what
I do yeah I'm reading stuff I'd like to
do some comedy honestly you know do
something lighter and then come back to
this something darker and mix it up I
mean lighten the mood please
it was really really really happy really
got any heavier than you know poisoning
your child and having surgeries done on
them no it's horrible about as heavy as
it gets it's one of those stories that
just resonates I think with everybody
and so many people watched and they
couldn't believe it
but then you see it's real you can
follow the documentation and that crazy
story it just gets crazier and crazier
as if that wasn't enough yeah then the
choices that Gypsy makes yes
those revelations all right here's my
question where's the party at tonight
you're going home you're just gonna yeah
and we're going all around no you're
getting it in tonight aren't you yes you
do enjoy this congratulations
I mean you deserve it it's been two
great performances back-to-back
[Music]